bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'eux samsung on va parler de rumeurs de
fuite très très très précise au niveau
du samsung
note 9 qui devrait arriver très
prochainement dans les mois à venir et
qu'il vous est arrivé un peu plus tôt
que prévu donc on va regarder ça
maintenant
samsung c'est une des marques qui innove
le plus qui fait beaucoup parler d'elle
et qui en tout cas un des leaders avec
apple se partagent tous les deux la
première marche du podium
un coup l'un un coup l'autre ça dépend
effectivement d'actualité de l'annnonce
de produits essayer ça avec les galaxy s
9,9 plus vraiment marqué un grand coup
en ayant des smartphones avec une
technologie de lentilles et ouverture
variable et ça c'est hyper sexy sur un
smartphone c'est une première donc là il
vraie innovation et il devrait continuer
à innover et notamment accès de gamme
note avec le note 9 ans déjà que notre
suite ils ont vraiment eu un produit qui
ressemblait en tout cas au samsung
galaxy s suite et ensuite plus un écran
infiniti un espen toujours très précis
un produit hyper sexy que j'ai vraiment
apprécié manipulés et que je trouve
super intéressant et là avec le note 9
il pourra aller plus loin effectivement
il écarte prochain petit peu au galaxy s
9 d'être un petit peu trop une évolution
et ne pas apporter grand chose de neuf
par rapport au galaxy elle suit j'en
suis pas persuadé un poste effectivement
sauf qu en termes de photographie ils
vont quand même beaucoup plus loin
alors il ya aussi effectivement ce super
slow motion en 720p en 60 images par
seconde
ça apporte pas grand chose parce que
vous allez pas forcément à voir
l'utilité autres cas pour le grand
public mais trouve que c'est vraiment
cool qui vit nov
on n'a pas effectivement la grande
innovation pour 2019 sur la gamme s
mais là a priori se note 9 pour être
vraiment hyper sexy et notamment on
devrait retrouver cette fois ci un
capteur d'empreinte digitale n'ont pas
situé au dos de l'appareil comme sans
menottes et où le s9 s9 plus souvent
cité suite plus pas situé en bas de
l'appareil comme sur les anciens modèles
ls sète et compagnie mais carrément 1,4
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran
et ça ça serait fondamentalement super
cool alors samsung serait pas le premier
à le faire les ja d'autres marques qui
le font mais l'intégrer à cette gamme de
samsung à la gamme note
c'est une innovation dans la marque et
ça c'est vraiment intéressant alors
c'est des rumeurs qui nous viennent
d'iran d'iran cette fois ci qui viennent
d'un site internet très intéressant et
qu'est ce qu'on apprend on à préfecture
mans que ce capteur d'empreintes
digitales pour esthétiquement situé sous
l'écran
parce que ce qu'on voit si vouvry
lorsqu'on regarde les images qui ont
fuité c'est qu'on ne voit pas de 80
empreintes digitales situé à l'arrière
alors il est évident que de toute façon
on voit pas non plus en bas sur la face
avant
ils vont pas nous en remettre un là
donc si le supprime à l'arrière s'il ne
met pas à l'avant vous avez deux
possibilités soit vous avez une
technologie un petit faith heidi avec
une canne hier un trou d'eps made in
samsung située à l'avant de l'appareil
qu'à faire un mapping en trois
dimensions pour vraiment sécurisé le
déverrouillage parce qu'aujourd'hui le
festin nu look de samsung est largement
pas suffisant
la reconnaissance par l'iris ou la
reconnaissance faciale c'est bien ça
marche en termes de sécurité c'est pas
génial génial
donc il faudrait une note techno comme
la caméra trou d'eps je suis pas sûr
very dessus mais par contre al intégrer
un capteur d'empreintes digitales
directement situées à l'écran quelque
chose qui existe chez d'autres
constructeurs
et pourquoi pas d'intégrer directement
chez eux donc ça serait vraiment très
intéressant et ça expliquerait pourquoi
on n'entre pas de capteur d'empreinte
digitale au dos de l'appareil
alors il y avait une autre rumeur qui
faisait état directement d'un très grand
écran qui couvrirait toute la face avant
de l'appareil c'est à dire pas de caméra
pas de haut parleurs rien du tout un
seul même et grand écran bon ce qu'on
voit sur les images qu'on fit
aujourd'hui c'est que ce n'est pas le
cas bientôt cette rumeur était
intéressante parce qu'elle disait
effectivement qu'avec cette nouvelle
typologie d'écran elle pourrait être
micro percée pour laisser passer
directement les leçons des haut parleurs
et pour pouvoir intégrer directement de
sous une caméra ça pourrait être
intéressant bon a priori là ça sera pas
le cas pour cette année mais c'était une
rumeur qui est en tout cas plutôt cool
et que je trouvais plutôt sexy à voir ce
qui pourrait arriver maintenant en 2019
est-ce que ça arrivera sur un samsung
galaxy s 10 est-ce que ça arrivera sur
un galaxy x pourquoi pas parce que toute
façon y 6 avec un écran pliable
on imagine que la vie reprendre
quasiment toute la phase de l'appareil
donc ça serait dommage d'avoir des
petits capteurs ci et là des encoches
des compagnies ci et ça non il faut
vraiment un produit révolutionnaire donc
ça reste égalité parce que on va en
parler très très prochainement dès qu'on
aura des infos donc abonnée vue alors à
l'arrière qu'est ce qu'on voit en trouve
un double module photo qui est centrée à
la verticale à l'avant on a un écran
oled de 6,3 pouces et bien évidemment le
sps peine qu'il devrait être encore plus
performant et qu'il devrait proposer de
nouvelles fonctionnalités logicielles
donc c'est à dire que on pourrait faire
pas mal de choses l'accueil spain on
pourra l'utiliser tout seul on peut
l'utiliser en combinaison avec les
doigts et on pourrait effectivement
utilisé aussi cet appareil tout seul
avec les doigts sans le respect mais ce
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
imaginez vous fait un trait à votre
espèce avec votre doigt vous allez
pouvoir à grand
dire le trait le faire plus et payer
moins épais y aurait plein dodge est
plein de raccourcis qui viendrait aussi
d'une combinaison espen avec vos doigts
et ça ça pourrait être vraiment très
intéressant et tout ça ça a été remarqué
par un brevet déposé directement par
samsung auprès de l'organisation
mondiale de la propriété intellectuelle
et c'est le site l'escaut digital qui
l'a remarqué et qui une fois de plus a
mis le doigt sur un brevet très
intéressant sur une techno que deux
coups on devrait retrouver sur ce note 9
de 2018 alors c'est un produit qui
pourrait arriver un peu plus tôt que
prévu qui pourrait être présenté dès le
mois de juillet de cette année est
commercialisé très rapidement pour
plusieurs raisons et notamment pour
couper un peu l'herbe sous le pied apple
pour éviter de trop souffrir la
concurrence avec apple parce que si vous
vous souvenez l'année dernière en 2017
apple a pris un petit peu de retard au
niveau de la commercialisation et de la
vente de ses iphones 10 alors autant les
modèles 8 et 8 plus était déjà prêt
autant l'iphone dit ce n'était pas prêt
là par contre il devrait sortir trois
nouveaux modèles dès le mois de
septembre et là ils seront dans les
starting blocks prêts à les
commercialiser donc effectivement la
crainte de san jose se retrouver un
petit peu en frontal au contraire en
proposant un produit qui est sexy qui
est innovant il pourrait un petit peu
contrer l'effet apple et réaliser des
ventes assez rapidement leur après est
ce que le consommateur attendra
néanmoins l'annoncé d'apple
peut-être peut-être pas allez savoir
toujours est il que c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment les smartphones se vendent un
petit peu moins bien que ce soit le
samsung galaxy s 9 s9 plus qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément été à la hauteur des
espérances de samsung en termes de vente
l'iphone disent aussi qu'ils avaient des
ventes relativement décevant car même si
effectivement apple a battu son record
du chiffre d'affaires ils ont battu plus
sur les autres produits sont des
produits complémentaires sur tout le
reste
mais en tout cas on voit que le taux de
renouvellement des smartphones est un
petit peu moins élevé on était à 1 an 2
en tête attend sur des reniements de
smartphones plus de deux ans trois ans
ce qui fait qu effectivement les ventes
dégringolent un petit peu alors pokou
stratégiquement il est hyper important
pour samsung de commercialiser cette
note 9 au bon moment pour capter le
maximum de personnes
il ya un sens de faria non ce mois de
juillet et d'avoir les précommandes très
rapidement pour garder de l'actualité
éviter que tout de suite apple jeanne un
petit peu grignoté des parts de marché
avec a priori c'est trois nouveaux
iphone mais ça vous avait déjà parlé
mais restez polis parce que on va
reparler très
prochainement alors d'un point de vue
purement techno à l'intérieur on y
retrouve un processeur exynos 9810 si
giga de ram et tourne sous android
8.1 oreo avec bien sûr la surcouche
expérience hui une batterie un peu plus
puissante cette année une 3850 millan
père heures il faut savoir quand même
que le galaxy note suite avait une
batterie de trois mille trois cent
millions terreur alors effectivement
avec le nôtre ils ont un petit peu
marcher sur des oeufs parce qu'il ya un
vrai fiasco au niveau de la batterie à
cause du galaxy note 7
le galaxy note 7 qui explosait si vous
vous souvenez vous du coup ils ont eu
tout retirer ça a coûté énormément
d'argent à samsung avec notre suite ils
l'on joue un petit peu petit bras mais
pour avoir un produit qui marche
regagner un petit peu là la confiance
est prouvé qu'ils avaient des produits
de bonne qualité
d'où une batterie de trois mille trois
cent millions terreur là à priori ils
sont pas au niveau des batteries donc il
remonte un petit peu la capacité 3850
millions terreur normalement tout
devrait bien se passer
on devrait pas avoir un produit qui nous
pèse dans les doigts cette année et
autre point intéressant des diversions 2
devrait faire son apparition cette année
sur le samsung note 9
ça c'est plutôt cool et leur après
effectivement s'écouler pas cool parce
que pour l'instant bixby n'est toujours
pas en français on peut faire des choses
indique ce billet on peut effectivement
faire la traduction
on peut faire des trucs ne peut pas
communiquer avec bixby en français et
c'est vraiment dommage et c'est vraiment
regrettable parce que bixby a été lancé
en même temps que la suite c'est à dire
il ya plus d'un an maintenant et on l'a
toujours pas français alors espérons
qu'avec bixby les deux cette fois ci on
est un vrai produit avec de vrais belle
interaction en français pour ça pas
obligé d'aller coller de la région
artificielle de
google par dessus ce serait quand même
vraiment vraiment vraiment dommage donc
voila un petit peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui pour le portrait robot de
cet appareil un premier temps on a
beaucoup parlé donc rester connecté
abonnez vous parce que vous allez voir
ça va être super cool
samsung sur des produits qui sont
concocté aux petits oignons des produits
hyper sympa à mon avis avec cette année
le note 9
ils ne vont pas dérogé à la règle et on
risque d'aller de surprise en surprise
et sur toute l'année prochaine on va
avoir la nouvelle gamme qui va arriver
savez les innove un an sur deux un an un
produit vraiment innovant c'est le cas
du et suit le s9 c'est le produit des
intérêts génération vraiment un an après
à deux ans il vous propose un nouveau
produit avec gros innovations on attend
toujours ce galaxy x galaxie 10 est ce
que ce sera le galaxy s 10 peut-être
peut-être pas toujours est il qu'à mon
avis en 2019 ça va être l'année de
toutes les surprises pour samsung
restez connectés comme d'hab vous
inquiétez pas on va en parler d'ici là
soyez sages vous fait des gros bisous
laissez-moi des plus des commentaires
marquera tout ce que vous voulez je vous
aime vous êtes les meilleurs
et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]